[Music]
hello and welcome to this special video
we want to share with you some exciting
recent developments in mathematical deep
learning for this miss coffeebean and i
are here today with guests from aleph
alpha the sponsor of this video
today we're gonna talk about a recently
published theory that uses physics to
gain a deeper understanding of deep
neural networks and to improve them
we'll introduce the basic principles
that underpin the theory and show you
what makes this so exciting in
particular we'll see how it can be
applied to optimize the initialization
of neural networks which will verify
experimentally the whole video is made
with the help of kuhn ostermeier and we
will do a second video like this one so
if you are interested in mathematical
deep learning subscribe to stay tuned so
we were saying that some exciting things
are happening in deep learning
this has culminated in a theoretical
framework that allows us to better
understand deep neural networks and
derive practically useful insights the
theory was introduced in a 407
page book by dan robert sho yaida and
boris hanin which is the result of
several years of research from the
authors
but of course they could not have done
it without earlier works by people such
as neil schoenholz lee matthews and
jacob among others or jacob in our
opinion the biggest contribution of the
book is that it provides a framework
that unifies this previous research and
extends it the theory and the book are
quite mathematically involved so we'll
do our best to make the explanations as
intuitive and visual as possible what do
you need as prerequisites for this video
we hope you're familiar with the basics
of statistics and multi-layer
perceptrons or short mlps because then
this video should be understandable for
you it also draws heavy inspiration from
physics and makes some really
interesting connections and will go into
that direction of physics too hopefully
you are as excited by this as we are
deep neural networks are notoriously
hard to capture mathematically they are
made up of millions if not billions of
parameters data are pushed through many
non-linearities and hidden layers that
mix them up until everything becomes
completely entangled this is why neural
networks are often referred to as black
boxes in the sense that the only
effective way to see how they work is to
just simply feed them data and see what
comes out
the current situation we're in is
similar to that of the history of the
steam engine back when the steam engine
was invented it was also regarded as a
black box you would put in coal and get
out work
the desire to better understand how
steam engines worked to increase their
efficiency led to the development of
thermodynamics which resulted in a
number of fundamental laws that could
describe the workings of the steam
engine in terms of simple measurable
quantities such as pressure and
temperature
when physicists discovered the laws of
thermodynamics largely experimentally
they didn't know about atoms yet later
boltzmann maxwell gibbs and others found
first principle explanations and it
became clear that pressure and
temperature are emergent phenomena
resulting from the statistical behavior
of many tiny molecules
in other words they realize that when
looking at a large scale many of the
irrelevant details of the individual
behavior of the microscopic components
get washed out if you want to know how
hot the steam is you don't need to know
the movement of every single particle
all you need to know is their collective
behavior described simply by a single
number the temperature
now to get back to neural networks in
analogy the microscopic statistical
constituents such as water molecules
correspond to the numerous parameters of
a neural network they behave
statistically since they're drawn from a
probability distribution
however for neural networks we already
know their microscopic behavior
very well we are the gods the
programmers that define them in our code
bringing them into being when we run our
networks
therefore to better understand neural
networks we need to follow this story in
the other direction
what is the macroscopic behavior of the
neural network given its microscopic
details
finding the neural network equivalent of
the fundamental laws of thermodynamics
could help the development of
intelligence in silico in the same way
understanding thermodynamics unleashed
the full power of the steam engine
during the industrial revolution
of course this might probably just be
wishful thinking and there are many
differences between neural networks and
physics but the theory that we're going
to discuss in this video is a step in
that direction because we want to
illustrate the ideas from the theory in
the simplest way possible we'll only use
basic mlps with gaussian weights and
biases but in principle there is no
reason why it can't be extended to more
modern architectures such as cnns and
transformers
okay so we want to understand what
happens when neural networks become
macroscopic what exactly do we mean by
this
a network becomes large as the width of
the network so the number of neurons in
each hidden layer increases with an
increasing number of neurons the network
becomes more and more independent of the
details and can be described by a small
set of variables however if we go all
the way to infinite width too many
details would be averaged out the model
you'll end up with has mathematically
pleasant behavior and nice closed form
solutions but on the other hand it has
lost a lot of what makes neural networks
interesting and effective in the first
place we are essentially approximating
cows with perfect spheres for some of
the calculations this infinite width
approximation works fine but for others
our cow will need her legs back meaning
we don't go all the way to infinity and
rather look at what happens at large but
not infinite width as we'll explain in
more details in a bit we can describe
this mathematically as a series
expansion in powers of one over the
width
in this expansion the zeroth order term
is a gaussian or more precisely a
gaussian process and is very easy to
work with the other terms in the series
scale with powers of one over the width
where the higher order the term the more
complicated its structure is so the
correction to the gaussian model form a
hierarchical structure of increasing
complexity
this is great news because this means
that for sufficiently large n we can
keep only the simplest correction term
and neglect all higher order terms as
long as we are fine with living with a
small error
by doing this we strike a nice balance
between the theory remaining
mathematically tractable but still
allowing for non-trivial finite with
effects
we will show you how this can be used to
derive optimal initialization of neural
networks by tuning the variances of the
weights and biases and understand how
the activation functions influence this
however the theory is much broader and
also covers training itself and how to
improve that that is actually the topic
of the next video in this series so stay
tuned
first let's understand how a gaussian
distribution arises in infinitely wide
neural networks and how finite ones
deviate from this
to get a feeling for this we'll play
around with some neural networks and see
what we get
to start with we'll take one of the
simplest neural networks there is one
with just two hidden layers and only one
neuron per layer you probably already
know this but just to shortly recap how
forward propagation works we start with
input data this is the vector x in our
case three-dimensional then it is
multiplied by a weight matrix visualized
as the connections in the first layer to
get the pre-activations of the first
hidden layer
now we'll not include any bias terms to
keep it simple we'll call this z1 where
the one refers to the fact that this is
the first hidden layer
next an activation function sigma is
applied to each of these neurons this
gives us the so called post activations
in our case we choose a ton h activation
function this is repeated for the other
hidden layers to finally produce the
output y
we want to investigate what kind of
statistical distributions the hidden
states of this neural network are so
let's start recording its values into
histograms
then we re-initialize the network and
see what values we get this time and
record them
as this process is repeated
distributions emerge
note that the input data is kept the
same so what we're seeing is the result
of randomness in the weights not in the
data in other words the weights induce a
distribution whose parameters are a
function of the input data so just keep
in mind that we treat the data set as
fixed and right now we're looking at a
single sample from this data set
so what did we get for the first
distribution we see that it's exactly
gaussian to illustrate this we can draw
a gaussian with the same variance in
mean as the empirical distribution and
see that the lines match up pretty much
exactly this makes sense since the
neurons in the first layer are equal to
the sum of the inputs multiplied by
gaussian weights and the weighted sum of
gaussian variables is also a gaussian
variable after the activation function
is applied it's pretty obvious that the
distribution isn't gaussian anymore for
one it gets squeezed between -1 and 1
the minimum and maximum values of the
tan h function moving on to the next
reactivation is this gaussian
it might have become a little more
gaussian but it's a bit too pointy so
even though this layer is also awaited
some of one element of gaussian
variables the weight is multiplied by
the stochastic variable sigma of z1
rather than a fixed input data vector
and when a gaussian variable is
multiplied with another stochastic
variable the resulting distribution in
general is not caution anymore therefore
this layer is non-gaussian as opposed to
the first one but this is again expected
after all we promised it would only
become gaussian for infinite n and n
equals 1 is still a bit off from
infinity
so let's move one step closer to
infinity and set n to 2. so we add an
extra neuron to the hidden layers and
repeat the process
just like before the first layer is
gaussian whereas the second is not but
this time the second one is slightly
wider to see better how it has changed
let's draw back in the distribution from
the previous network and the gaussian
indeed the difference of the gaussian
distribution the purple line seems
smaller compared to the n equals 1
distribution
and this difference shrinks even further
as n increases
so for sufficiently large networks all
the pre-activations of the hidden layers
are gaussian distributions with a
variance that is a function of the input
data and deviations from this scale
inversely with n
the reason why this is happening might
already be familiar to you what's at
play here is essentially the central
limit theorem which says that when you
take a properly scaled average of a
number of random samples drawn from a
probability distribution this average
will tend towards a normal distribution
this is actually the backbone of a lot
of applied statistics where we don't
know the underlying distribution but
knowing that it becomes caution is
enough in neural networks the value of a
neuron is also a sum of random samples
namely the post activations multiplied
by their respective weights the scaling
of the variance makes sure the sum is
properly scaled we can split off the
effects that come from the width and
write the distribution as a series
expansion in 1 over n
at the zeroth order we find our gaussian
which is indeed the only term that is
left when n goes to infinity and all the
other terms scale with increasing powers
of 1 over n and reshape the distribution
so why do we need to add correction
terms to the gaussian obviously it gives
a better approximation but there are
also a number of qualitative phenomena
that a distribution with non-gaussian
corrections can handle that the purely
gaussian one can't to see where these
differences come from let's start with
the expression for the gaussian
probability distribution describing a
single pre-activation neuron in the
infinite width limit like in our
previous experiments and built things up
from there
here the neuron value is called z it's
centered around the mean new and has a
variance of k
normally there would be a constant in
front to normalize the distribution but
we'll leave that out for now
the first thing to note is that the mean
of the neurons is zero the network is
initialized using gaussian weights that
also have mean 0 so we don't have to
worry about this
like we saw before the variance is a
function of the input data for each data
point the distribution will have a
different variance to account for this
the variance has to become a covariance
matrix which tells you what the
variances corresponding to the different
data points are on its diagonal but also
covariances between data points in the
off diagonal elements we label the data
using greek letters to keep track of
this we'll write the matrix
multiplication as an explicit sum
the covariance matrix can also be viewed
as a kind of kernel or similarity metric
you can take two data points and the
kernel will tell you how similar their
resulting neuron distributions will be
for mlps the covariance matrix of a
layer is a function of the inner product
between the post activation values of
the previous layer
to get a distribution for all the
neurons in the layer we generalize this
expression further and add neuron labels
with a lowercase roman letter okay so
our distribution p of sets now describes
all the neurons for all the different
data points in a single layer and we
have a z for each neuron and each data
point note that the covariance matrix
doesn't depend on the neuron index this
implies that the distributions of all
the neurons are the same it has to be
like this that's because if we were to
interchange two neurons nothing would
change so they're all the same this also
means that the neurons are statistically
independent recall that two variables
are independent if their joint
distribution is equal to the product of
their individual distributions
because we have a sum in the exponent
where each of the terms depends on a
different neuron we can easily rewrite
the distribution as the product of the
distributions of the individual neurons
you might think that the fact that we
ignore correlations between neurons is
overly simplistic but this is a feature
not a bug the simplest level of
approximation should be simple
as a consequence a lot of the formulas
can be expressed in terms of easy
one-dimensional gaussian integrals
however there are indeed two limitations
that an infinite width network has and
which can be fixed by adding finite
width corrections these are the
inability to wire and to learn
representations wiring is a concept that
originates from hebbian learning a
neurological theory about how neurons in
the brain adapt as they learn it is
often summarized by the phrase neurons
that fire together wire together in the
context of artificial neural networks
this refers to two neurons that are
correlated such that if the first neuron
has an atypical value
so it is firing the other neuron will be
more likely to have a typical value as
well neurons that deviate similarly like
this will be pulled together during the
training process strengthening their
correlation this is what the wiring
refers to the other thing that the
infinite width network cannot do is
representation learning when a finite
width neural network is trained the
distribution of neurons in the hidden
layers will evolve meaning they learn
non-random internal features
but in the infinite width limit this
process gets washed out meaning the
distributions before and after a step of
gradient descent are equal in such
models the second to last layer outputs
a set of random features and the output
layer is basically a linear model that
is fitted on these it therefore doesn't
matter how many layers it has which
completely defeats the whole point of
deep learning we also wouldn't have had
to bother with sgd since training the
network has been reduced to a simple
linear regression problem for which
there is a closed form solution this is
why infinite with neural networks are
said to be linear the root cause of
these issues is the uncorrelatedness of
the neurons wiring requires correlations
between neurons and representation
learning requires correlation between
layers
as promised finite width networks
alleviate this by virtue of the fact
that they have higher order terms the
first of which is v
if we include only this one the
expression for the distribution looks
like this
to avoid getting confused by all the
indices and sums let's restrict to only
two neurons and a single data point so
we don't need to write the data indices
and can label the neurons with one and
two respectively the previous argument
that we use to show that the neurons are
statistically independent namely that we
can factorize their distribution doesn't
hold anymore the z1 squared times that
two squared terms ruins this by mixing
up the neurons we don't have the time to
go fully in depth into how exactly this
causes wiring and representation
learning but to give a rough explanation
the new v term acts like an excess
kurtosis term that makes the
distribution more sensitive to outliers
causing a wiring effect with a strength
proportional to v and the v term
modifies the effective covariances
allowing for non-linear effects
now that we understand the structure of
the probability distribution of neural
networks there is still the open
question how do we even go about
computing it
so far our analysis has been quite
abstract and you might expect that
computing distributions for all the
layers of a deep neural network gets
very complicated but luckily that's not
the case we've seen that the network is
completely specified by its covariance
matrix and terms such as v that are
functions of the input data so if we can
compute those we know everything we need
there are two insides here that we can
use to calculate these
first we already know exactly what the
distribution of the first layer is even
at finite width namely perfectly
gaussian as we saw in our experiments
and secondly the layers are related to
each other via the layer equation which
tells you the values of a layer as a
function of those of the previous layer
if we can somehow bootstrap from the
first layer to the second layer then
from there to the third layer etc we can
work our way through the whole network
indeed that's what we will do
for all of the parameters that define a
neural network we can derive the
so-called recursion relations that will
allow us to compute their value as a
function of the values in the previous
layer then we simply apply this
repeatedly starting from the known
values of the first layer and find all
of them let's illustrate this by
deriving the recursion relation for the
variance at infinite width resulting
from a single data point don't worry
this will only take a few steps to
derive but we'll show you the basic idea
okay so how do we turn the layer
equation into an equation of variance
well we can simply compute the variance
of both sides recall that b is the bias
term w i are the weights and sigma is
the activation function
on the left hand side we have by
definition the variance of layer l plus
one and on the right hand side both the
bias and the weights have predefined
variances
c b and c w divided by n respectively
all the neurons have the same
distribution and are independent so we
can ignore the index i and that's it
the left hand side is the variance of
layer l plus 1 and the right hand side
is a function of the variance of layer l
because the expectation value is
computed using a gaussian distribution
with that variance let's also appreciate
how simple this expression is we've
condensed a complicated high-dimensional
neural network into a simple
one-dimensional integral formula
in the finite width limit the above
calculation would still hold but we
would have an error term of order one
over n
and when we apply this recursion
relation multiple times these error
terms accumulate linearly and will
therefore scale like l over n at layer l
before we go on we should probably check
empirically how well the theory actually
works so far this has all hinged on the
assumption that the terms in the one
over n expansion shrink fast enough that
you get good approximations for
realistic neural network sizes in
addition we also saw that error is
accumulated as the network gets deeper
we take a network with tanh activation
functions at different widths on the
x-axis we plot the layer number and on
the y-axis the variance we first work
out what we would expect theoretically
starting from an initial variance of one
this is what the dots indicate then we
run some simulations at different widths
the variances can easily be found by
recording the pre-activation values
squared
as the width increases the empirical
results like closer to the theoretical
one which is to be expected
already for a width of 50 which is well
within the reach of what's practically
possible the errors have already become
pretty small furthermore it seems that
for larger values the variance converges
to a fixed value so at some point the
error levels out this of course depends
on the variances of the weights and
biases and the activation function so
this is by no means a general result but
it shows that it is possible to get a
good correspondence between theory and
practice even for relatively narrow
neural networks
before we go on let's give some
interpretation to our new perspective on
neural networks we saw that we can
understand neural networks as sequential
processes that change a representation
of the data from layer to layer these
representations are expressed as
covariance matrices and other parameter
tensors like v and together they define
the neuron distributions of each layer
or in other words the internal features
our formalism tracks the evolution of
features throughout the network
when the network is trained we start
from a representation
which contains all the information and
step by step this gets distilled into a
more abstract higher level
representation this is very reminiscent
of a heuristic picture of how neural
networks work internally called the
hierarchy of feature maps
you've probably heard this idea before
in a cnn that can detect cows this would
look something like this the features of
the lower layers are responsible for
detecting small low-level features such
as edges lines and textures then in the
middle layers these are turned into
mid-level features like shapes and basic
patterns which are then further combined
into high level eyes ears others and
other body parts and finally the most
abstract representation namely the label
in particular whether there's a cow or
not another idea that is similar to this
one is one of the most widely used
techniques in modern physics called
renormalization which shows up
everywhere from phase transitions
superfluidity and magnetization to
particle physics and certain
formulations of quantum gravity
this is a process of removing unwanted
degrees of freedom sadly we don't have
time to go deeper into this but the
techniques used in renormalization are
the basis for our analysis in the next
part
we can imagine the parameters of our
distribution such as k starting at a
point in parameter or theory space and
watch how they run as we repeatedly
apply the recursion formula with the
layer number acting as a kind of time
index
in this diagram we see the values of the
covariance matrix of a neural network
with jelly activation functions for
different start positions
the x-axis shows the variance of the
neurons induced by a data point labeled
alpha and on the y-axis there is
covariance between data points alpha and
beta the counter on the right indicates
which layer we're at
this is known as a representation flow
one thing we immediately notice is that
the values that start in the bottom half
all converge to a single point whereas
the top ones drift off to infinity this
is called a fixed point which is defined
as a point in parameter space that when
you apply renormalization you end up
with the same point again we treat
infinity also as a point so we can say
that all parameters in this graph
converge to a fixed point which is about
1 for the parameters starting in the
bottom half and infinity for the ones
starting in the top half we also saw
this behavior in the experimental
verification in the previous part where
the quantities converged to a specific
value we can compute the value of the
fixed point by taking the recursion
equation and solving it for k l equals k
l plus 1 which we'll call k star like we
said at this value by definition the
input value will be the same as the
output value
there are essentially two different
kinds of fixed points trivial fixed
points where the value of the parameter
diverges exponentially and shoots off to
infinity or dies down to zero these
destroy the structure of the data at an
exponential rate this is what you want
to avoid when training a neural network
non-trivial fixed points are those where
the value of the parameter converges to
a finite point preserving some of the
structure of the data
flowing to a non-trivial fixed point
seems to be a necessary condition for a
deep learning network to perform well
this can include the fixed point value
zero as long as the convergence isn't
exponential this technically also
destroys the data but at a manageable
rate and in practice we see that this
also works well
we can further characterize fixed points
by looking at their immediate
neighborhood
imagine you're drifting close to a fixed
point
again there are several things that can
happen it could be that the flow will
suck you into the fixed point or that
you drift away from it and if you're
exactly on the cusp you remain at the
same distance
to quantify which direction the current
will take you we introduce a parameter
chi called the susceptibility
for chi smaller one you'll be pulled in
at an exponential rate towards the fixed
point while for chi greater than one
you're pushed away exponentially and for
chi equals one you stay at the same
distance for neural networks since we're
working with higher dimensional vectors
the deviation from the fixed point can
be both in the direction of the data or
in parallel and perpendicular to the
data this means we have two types of
susceptibility
rather than one the first quantity is
called the parallel susceptibility
obviously and the second one is the
perpendicular susceptibility also
obviously to get a bit of intuition the
first corresponds to the difference in
magnitude between two nearby inputs as
they pass through the network and the
latter corresponds to their relative
distance but also controls vanishing and
exploding gradients
in practical terms a susceptibility of
one is beneficial for neural networks
because this means that points that are
apart will not collapse into each other
what we find in practice though is that
having a susceptibility close to one is
enough to get well-behaving flows we
also see that the perpendicular
susceptibility is much more important
than the parallel one this has probably
to do with the fact that it controls the
size of gradients and lastly exploding
perturbations such as chi perpendicular
greater than one are more harmful than
shrinking ones chi perpendicular smaller
than one the equations for these
susceptibilities aren't too hard to
derive they're basically taking
derivatives of the fixed point equation
but we've done enough maths for today in
the end we have three equations that
determine what values cb and cw have to
be a network that is theoretically
initialized optimally
now to the part which really shows the
power of the theory strictly speaking
all of what we have just said only holds
for neural networks at initialization
and there is no theoretical guarantee
that any of this generalizes to the rest
of training but what we find out in our
experiments is that actually the
initialization has a strong effect on
how well a network trains and is largely
determined by the parallel
susceptibility having said that we
should keep in mind that these are
vanilla mlps so modern tricks that make
sure networks train better such as skip
connections and batch or layer
normalization are not considered for the
experiments we ran some sweeps over
ranges of the variance of the weights
and biases cb and cw respectively for a
50 layer mlp with a hidden size 500.
each network is trained for 10 epochs on
mnist and at the end of each training
run we recorded their accuracy on a
separate evaluation set solving the
previous equations we find that there is
a stable fixed point at c b equals zero
and c w equals two this is also known as
chi ming initialization which is just a
special case of our methods relu has
another special property when cw equals
2 and cb is not equal to 0 the variance
grows linearly in the layer number since
this is not an exponential growth this
is technically also a non-trivial fixed
point
the line represents the values of same
perpendicular susceptibility
and the background color is the accuracy
obtained on the test set so basically
the brighter the better performant the
network the solid line is the
theoretical optimum which lies indeed in
the region with the best accuracies but
values near the line also perform well
performance drops off quicker for chi
perpendicular greater one
to the right of the solid line
than for kai perpendicular smaller than
1 on the left
this agrees with the idea that vanishing
gradients are less bad than exploding
ones
the yellow high accuracy is well
enclosed by the dotted lines
representing the range chi perpendicular
in between 0.8 and 1.1 overall this
shows a very strong agreement between
theory and practice
repeating the same analysis for tanh
activation functions gives the following
plot we see again that the high accuracy
region is nicely enclosed by the dotted
lines and that higher than one
susceptibility is worse than lower than
one it is kind of hard to see but as we
follow the lines upwards the accuracy
slightly drops this is due to the
parallel susceptibility which decreases
for larger values of c b
for jello we see again that the
accuracies strongly correlated with the
perpendicular susceptibility on the left
side the lines coincide with the yellow
region on the right side however the
lines move into the low accuracies this
is an area of quickly changing
susceptibility causing this to be an
unstable region
reloose 6 is the same as relu but values
larger than 6 get squashed down to 6.
this causes the lines to tilt to the
right this is also reflected in the
accuracies that we find from the
experiments which again match up with
the lines so i hope you are convinced by
theory and experiment
and wow what a video this was i hope we
have a better understanding now of what
weights and biases and activation
functions do in a neural network and
that we have a pretty good idea how to
initialize the network optimally thanks
to carla for visiting us today and
thanks to kuhn that took care of the
script of the video and the cool
visualizations in manim this video would
not have happened without him and thanks
to pip for the amazing drawings
and of course thanks to alef alpha for
making this video possible
lf alpha from heidelberg germany is one
of the europe's leading ai research and
development companies
loaded with top international ai talent
lf alpha researches develops and
operationalizes large generalizable ai
models just very recently they released
two large language models from their
luminous series the luminous series
offers users for the first time a made
in europe alternative to large ai
language models from the usa or china
their multilingual multimodal ai models
can be accessed via an api as well as
through an interactive user interface
additionally they just released a
multimodal method called magma which
enables pre-trained transformers to use
images as input format i mean it even
recognizes miss coffee being look alive
alpha is committed to spark constructive
discussions with research and open
source communities to enhance the
development of transformative ai
applications that's why they recently
open sourced the code base for magma
find the link to the paper in the video
description
from research to development to
implementation alef alpha strives to
align modern generalizable ai research
sustainably with ethical values to
achieve that they continuously search
for the best talent and partners
for more information visit their
playground under
app.lfminusalpha.com and don't forget to
subscribe to their twitter account via
the handle alif underscore underscore
alpha thanks for watching and see you
next time
two types of sus su
this means we have two types of
successful